- My name's Michael Grinich.
I'm the founder and CEO of WorkOS.
We are a company that helps developers
with authentication, identity,
really all the enterprise features
that you need to add to your product
as you take it up market and
sell it to bigger customers.
But today I'm not here to talk about that.
I'm here to talk about something else,
this little thing called agents.
How many of you are
building things with AI
or experimenting with AI agents today?
Amazing, it's a ton of hands going up.
What's crazy is I gave a
very similar talk to this
about six months ago,
and there were like two hands
that went up in the audience.
So it feels like agents
on this growth rate
is starting to take over.
And what I'm gonna talk about here
is actually security and permissions
and really identity as it applies
to this new world of agents
and how that's different
than what we've been doing
in the past for people.
All right, so let's
jump in and get started.
And I'll start here with a story.
So imagine that you are building
the next great LLM chatbot for your team,
kind of like an internal chat GPT
that your team can use
to do specific actions,
can handle specific tasks,
maybe answer questions.
And for this example,
say that it's like an AI onboarding agent.
So it's helping your team with IT support.
So you've hooked it up
to internal systems.
Maybe you're using MCP,
the model context protocol
or some other agent
framework to connect it.
And for this AI onboarding agent,
you need to give it access
to a production database.
So it can actually read
data about your company
and do specific actions, right?
So you just connect it to Postgres
or Aurora or whatever you have,
just like your normal app.
And a user logs in and says,
"Okay, what should we build today?
"Well, let's delete some unused files
"to clear up some space."
The LLM is like, "Great idea.
"I went ahead and deleted
the production database."
Not great.
And this might seem like
kind of a fake example
or something that's hypothetical,
but this actually happened
almost exactly like this
a few months ago on one of
these new vibe coding platforms
where a developer was building an app
through peer prompting,
chatting with one of the
new foundational models
that's very smart and
great at writing code,
but then decided to drop the
entire production database.
So you might wanna lock this down.
But what about if you're
connecting something like,
you know how to lock down a database,
maybe row-level security,
but what if you need to connect it to Jira
or then connect it to Salesforce
or connect it to Slack?
Where do you draw the line
in terms of permissions for these systems?
These AI systems are only valuable
if you connect it to
all your stuff, right?
It can't do anything unless it's connected
to all of your data systems.
And at the end of the day also,
if this agent deletes
a production database,
who's responsible?
So these are questions that are really new
in the world of AI agent development.
In the past, a person
might have been responsible
or you could scope down privileges,
but it's very different with agents.
You have to give them broad
access to lots of things,
they have to have lots of
different capabilities,
and they can do stuff really quickly.
The shift here is that we really
need to think about agents
as first-class identities,
first-class identities.
So not just people as identities,
but actually agents in these systems
as identities.
And it's complicated because
agents aren't just machines.
There's been a lot of
research and a lot of work
on machine identity, doing
certificate, mutual TLS.
You probably all have
seen systems like that.
But agents kind of behave a
little bit more like people.
They collaborate with
people in similar ways.
They go use other
applications like people.
They might interface through an API,
but they also might interface
actually through a browser.
'Cause a lot of these products
that agents will go and use
maybe don't have APIs, or
the API is not as natural.
Imagine an API going and
using something like Figma.
It kind of has to go click
in the UI to be able to do stuff.
And so this is a major shift
around how we think about
identity authentication,
and really this new
paradigm for both engineers
building this, as well as enterprise IT,
who's gonna be responsible
for ultimately securing this,
and they're on the line,
they're on the hook
if things get deleted.
So really what I'm gonna talk about here
is this problem around
identity for agents.
Some ideas that we have around it,
some things that I've
seen around research.
But this is, I'm just gonna
tell you now, it's unsolved.
It is a brand new thing.
And my ask to all of you is
that we need to come together
to work on a new standard
for agent identity.
Okay, well let's jump in
and talk more about this.
So this growing trend is really about
agents interacting across different tools.
They're acting on behalf of users.
So agents can be standalone,
kind of synthetic individuals,
but really often they're more similar
to people I mentioned.
And in many cases, they actually need
a different type of data access.
So in some cases you would think,
let's just scope down the agent,
but in other cases you
need to actually connect it
really broadly to a lot
of different systems.
You know, if you have like
a super support agent,
you gotta connect it to everything for
it to have the context.
Really this is about context,
to be able to make decisions and do stuff.
And I think the implication
here is really that
identity in the applications
of what you're building,
they need to support
this machine identity,
this agent identity natively.
The machine-to-machine
system is not a fit.
And if you're thinking like,
okay, maybe six months
ago this wasn't a need,
your hand didn't go up
around building agents,
you're not convinced,
this is so, so powerful for new products
that if you don't incorporate this way
of building new applications
into your workplace,
you're not gonna be competitive.
Your products won't be
able to keep market.
Someone else that's able to harness
this power of agentic software development
will disrupt you.
So there's also a lot of
problems that we need to solve,
but I wanna reinforce
there's a lot of urgency
around doing this.
You know, one month in the
AI world feels like 10 years.
And it's just accelerating.
So we need to quickly find solutions here.
Okay, well, why is it fundamentally hard?
Like, why can't we just adapt
some existing patterns to agents?
Well, it makes this different
than maybe the previous
ways that we've done
authentication or identity for people,
or authentication and
identity for machines,
machine identity.
Well, the first thing is like,
the way that agents
work with these systems
is like headless.
So an agent might need
to log into a browser
and do something,
but it's not really clicking around
and using the browser necessarily.
They need to have this sort
of like token persistence
over long periods of time,
long periods of invocations.
You don't want an agent needing to
sign in every single day.
I think the joke is always
about single sign-on.
You have to do it every 24 hours, right?
Agents, you need it to be
long-lived and durable.
And so we can't just adapt
the existing patterns
around sessions or identity to agents.
We actually have to do something
that's gonna be a long-lived credential.
And we need to be able to verify
that it's authentic
over this period of time
without a login page.
It's kind of like an API token.
How do we do these long-lived sessions?
Where do those credentials live?
How do the agents store it securely?
These are all questions
that are not answered yet.
That's one of the things
that makes this hard,
is agents need to operate
in a way that's headless.
The second which I touched
on a little bit here
is least privilege.
So we all know probably this pattern,
it's best practice around security.
It's having least privileges.
Taking a system and its access control
and scoping it down to only what it needs.
On the one hand, you wanna do this,
but on the other hand, if
you're building an agent
that needs to go off and
have some cross-system access
or cross-system behavior,
you actually need to have
sort of a most privileges.
You need to actually expand it.
What happens when the
agent needs to do something
it doesn't have a permission for?
How do you escalate that?
In a company, if a person does this,
they would escalate it to the IT team.
They would create a ticket,
ask for the permission,
be escalated, and then hopefully,
if it's a mature IT org,
that would be de-escalated at some time.
Become an admin in a certain tool
and then have it drop down later.
For an agent, you might
need this to be done
hundreds of times an hour.
Probably can't be a manual approval flow,
but still has the same need to be audited
and logged and secure.
So permissions here need to be dynamic,
including permission escalation.
Least privileges model is
really about static permissions,
not about dynamic permissions.
So it's another thing that makes it hard.
Third, compliance.
There's an old saying, "To err is human,
"but to screw up 10,000 times per second,
"you need a computer."
And I think this is the
case also with agents.
Who did what?
What agent went off the rails
and built a ton of stuff?
Exfiltrated your data?
These LM systems, there's a
lot of risk and prompt jacking.
People being able to
take advantage of them
and have them do things that are unsavory.
So we talked about in terms
of the privilege model,
but in terms of compliance,
you need to have a full, deep audit log
of who did what and when.
Today, audit logs are mostly
around people activity,
humans doing things.
And there's just a
limit to how many things
people can do inside of a company.
But as soon as you start having agents,
hundreds, maybe thousands of these,
it's gonna get a lot more challenging.
So compliance is actually, I think,
one of the biggest problems
that's not being discussed
when people building agents.
There's a lot of agent frameworks.
There's a lot of new tools
and techniques for this
that people are giving talks around.
No one's talking about
compliance, but we are here.
If you even think about something
like a log aggregation
system, like a SIEM,
if you've ever used something
like Splunk or Panther
for this, those need to
be adapted to agents.
So just to show you, we
need to go all the way
through the full ecosystem
to be built for this world.
Okay, so those are a few things
that make it challenging.
Now I wanna switch gears and talk about
some architectural
patterns that I have seen
other people start building.
These are really just some kind of ideas
as people are thinking about identity
for agents that have emerged.
None of these are necessarily
like standards yet.
They're really just ways that people
have been approaching this problem.
Then they have advantages
and disadvantages.
I'll talk through each of them,
just to give you a flavor
of what's out there.
The four are persona
shadowing, delegation chains,
capability tokens, and
escalation to humans,
human in the loop.
So let's start with persona shadowing.
So what does this mean?
Well, it's kind of like impersonation.
So you've probably seen
this with a SaaS product
where you can go impersonate
one of your users.
You can log into the tool as them
and see the product as
the user would see it.
But really, what persona
shadowing here is about
is actually giving an agent
an independent identity.
So it's not acting as you,
it's actually sort of a reflection of you
that shadows a user.
Inside of an identity system,
this could be like a secondary user
or maybe something like a service account
that has a subset of those privileges.
And what this lets a system do
is sort of enforce stricter limits.
And it can trace agent
access to those actual agents
that are doing the
things versus the people.
Today, a lot of agent activity,
like scripts that people hack together
or systems that people are using,
they actually just use your identity.
They'll use your actual
login into these systems.
And so any activity the agent does
looks like it was actually you doing it.
This is one step away from that,
where it's kind of taking
your persona and shadowing it
and building sort of
derived identity from it.
So you still stay, if you're
Matt, you stay Matt prime,
but you might have like Matt agent one,
Matt agent two, Matt agent three.
So this provides this
isolation and accountability.
Every action is actually
explicitly tied to an agent.
And it's distinct from the delegated user.
The problem with this
is that impersonation
generally gives too much power.
And if you're doing this
kind of like shadowing,
it's very hard to scope
down the roles enough.
And again, I keep going back to this,
like where's the permission boundary?
Too wide, too narrow,
too wide, too narrow.
That's the challenge of persona shadowing.
But it's kind of the
first one people reach for
'cause it feels pretty natural.
All right, let's keep going.
Two, delegation chains.
So AI agents often will
call other services.
So you'll have an agent
that starts doing one thing.
And then what it'll actually do
is it'll go call out to sub-agents
or connect to other systems.
And the idea of a delegation chain
is that there's actually
a way for that identity,
that agent system, to be passed
from one system to another.
Kind of like a credential,
kind of like handing
somebody your AWS badge,
which you shouldn't do.
But that idea of it getting passed around
so other people can access things.
Or handing somebody maybe
your Costco membership,
which you also shouldn't do.
(laughs)
This preserves this end-to-end trust
and through the context of these hops.
And the design here is that this agent
must actually be caring for
the user's original authorization.
So their original kind
of set of permissions
are carrying it forward step-by-step.
And it needs to be verified
by these different agents.
So you kind of need like a third party
that you can check the permission against.
If you've ever used things like JWTs,
which are cryptographically signed
and have some information within,
and that can be passed
from different systems.
You can check, just check the signature.
The signature and date is valid.
It's good to go.
That's kind of a version
of delegation chains.
And so this is another
idea that people have
around identity for agents.
Is creating the agent, but
not naming the agent itself,
but giving it a credential
that can then be passed around.
Sub-agents are becoming
a very, very popular
kind of like programming model.
It's a model for building
agentic experiences.
It lets you manage context.
You can give a whole talk
about context management
for AI systems.
One of my favorite
AI-based coding products
actually does this, where you
ask it to build something.
And it says, I'm gonna
go consult the architect.
And there's a sub-agent that acts
as like an architectural consultant
and then brings it back in, right?
And so if you wanted this idea
of having a credential
that's passed around,
you could do it through delegation chains.
This is another pattern in
bringing identity to agents.
It's kind of like shadow
users are essentially,
shadow users kind of
getting passed around.
This is actually supported today
in some of the things
I mentioned around JWTs
and some things like OIDC, OpenID Connect.
It's been a pattern
that's existed previously
in web engineering, but being applied now
for agent identity, agent engineering.
Cool.
Three, capability-based tokens.
So previously what I
was talking about was,
having kind of a single
identity given to an agent
or a single credential given to an agent.
You kind of mint it
once, the agent gets it,
it goes and does stuff with it.
There's another way of doing this,
which is giving credentials
for one specific task.
So you really can scope
it down to a single thing
that it's trying to do.
It's kind of like a stamped
ticket for one action.
And this is like a capability-based token.
Example of a capability-based
token would be like,
agent X can read Bob's calendar
for the next 60 minutes.
That's it.
So that token is not actually
an identity for that agent,
it's a credential that it
can use to go do something.
And again, like the
permissions are tied in
to the token itself.
It's kind of like a secure
voucher for like one resource,
or even one action.
You can imagine a capability-based token
being used for one API call.
You're gonna use it
once and throw it away.
Maybe a payment, like
a single payment link.
So unlike a human which might
log in with broad permissions,
an agent could be given this
different capability token
for each task or resource.
You can even imagine a service
that's vending these things out.
That's saying, you wanna do this thing?
Okay, I'll let you do it, but just once.
So it lets you create
this really scoped down
set of privileges.
These tokens can be like time-bound,
they can be self-contained,
they can be very easy to verify.
But the problem again,
it's kind of the opposite
of what I was talking about earlier.
You gotta keep getting 'em.
You gotta keep checking 'em out.
You have to have a service
that can keep generating these.
And you sort of centralize
the permission creation moment
into some service that's creating these.
But this is a pretty powerful pattern.
I actually think this
will emerge more and more
within internal IT systems,
where you wanna have a centralized log
and a centralized kind of
credential management system,
and you're sort of checking
out the ability to do stuff.
And the agents are kind of calling in.
In a way, it's almost like doing a RPC.
You're not actually
doing the function call,
the procedure call,
but you're sort of getting the voucher,
the token, to be able to do that.
It's as good as calling the thing, right?
Getting the permission to
do that one function call.
Today, the tokens that exist
inside of typical OAuth scopes
are not this granular,
but there are some examples of people
kind of hacking it to do this.
If you've ever OAuthed with a service,
and there's a dropdown where you can say
how long the token's gonna be valid,
you can say forever, or
you can say one hour.
That's sort of an example
of a capability-based
token out in the wild.
But again, with agents,
'cause they're gonna do so much stuff,
we have to really scope them down.
Okay, capability-based tokens.
The last one here, for
the humanists in the room,
is escalation to humans.
We are still in control.
If all else fails, bail
out, call the human.
Actually have the human
give the permission check.
Run the inline, actually,
experience of approval.
This is really about approval flows.
And I think this will always be part
of how people bring
identity and permissions
and authorization to agents,
'cause ultimately, there
will still be things
that you want to be in the loop for.
There will always be something
that you want the agent to not do.
Even if designed to do that thing,
you say confirm with me before
you actually go do that.
Confirm with me before you
send the wire transfer,
before you file my taxes,
before you sell my car,
or whatever, right?
So human in loop will still be a thing.
And the idea here is
the escalation to human
can really kind of add
these consent checkpoints.
Now, again, the downside of this,
if you have agents going
out and doing everything,
they can't ask you every time.
And what I've seen, even in the world
of like Chats GPT and MCP stuff,
is you get this consent fatigue.
If you keep asking the
user, hey, are you sure?
Are you sure?
Guess what users do?
Click, click, click,
click, get out of my way.
I just wanna get my stuff done.
Human in the loop, escalation to human
becomes less effective
the more it's applied.
So it needs to be, like
the cookie monster says,
it's a sometimes food.
Don't always escalate to humans.
Only do it when it's
important or necessary.
But again, then there's the question,
when is it important to loop in humans?
These are all just different patterns,
architectural patterns, and
I think the right solution
is actually combining
these things together.
You might have some
capability-based tokens,
but that capability-based token might have
an attribute that requires
you to be in the loop.
It can initially say, hey, you're able
to create the wire transfer,
but to initiate it,
you have to get approval from me,
and there's like a tag on it
to be able to do that stuff.
So these can be composed together
to actually create the type of behavior
that you want in your product.
And when you're building
these objective systems,
I don't think there's one size fits all.
Only you can know about
the right permission model,
the right threat model, what
the risks or concerns are,
whether there will be
consent fatigue or not.
Maybe you don't need to worry about
escalation to a human being fatigued
if you're escalating it
to the head of compliance,
who you know is gonna
take it more seriously,
versus escalating it to a support rep
who might just be trying
to get about their job.
And so really, these four
things combined together,
I think, can give you a good foundation
for how to think about building
security or permissions
into your own agent-based workflows.
And they all kind of tie
into that identity permission side.
Okay, so I've given you a
few architectural examples up here.
Also, around identity for agents,
and just generally identity
in what we build at WorkOS,
there are a lot of acronyms.
So buckle up, we're about to enter
the acronym zone of this talk.
And what I'm gonna talk about is actually
some of these new protocols
that have emerged,
and new emerging standards all
around identity and agents.
So this is stuff that's
not done in the world yet.
It's kind of in the proposal state.
But things you might start hearing about
over the next few months
or the next few years
as people are building
more and more systems
to interface with agents.
All right, so here's some
emerging standards and protocols.
The first, not really emerging,
it's our old friend, OAuth.
OAuth 2.0/OpenIDConnect.
OAuth and OpenIDConnect
are pretty related,
kind of a superset of the protocol.
But we all know OAuth, right?
We've all signed in with our
Facebook account somewhere,
our Google account.
This has been around for quite a while.
And OAuth was designed
initially so that users
could explicitly grant this third-party
access, limited access,
without sharing passwords.
At the end of the day,
you don't wanna give an agent a password.
You don't want the
password in the context.
You don't want it in the agent's memory
'cause agents are unreliable.
The LLMs are unreliable.
Someone can get that password out.
So with OAuth, being able
to do this delegated access,
being actually kind of give
this consent and approve it,
is actually a pattern I've seen
with most of these agent systems.
If you're using one of
these products like Zapier
or N8n, when you're connecting
all these systems together,
the first way you connect
these things together
is through OAuth.
This brings your identity
from other systems into it.
So to give this identity
to agents is through OAuth.
Now, the limitation is that
OAuth was built for people.
It was built for human consent.
And so for an agent to try to sign in
through an OAuth-based system is tough.
It actually has to run a browser.
There's usually a lot
of machine detection.
There's automated attacks that
happen on OAuth endpoints.
We've actually at WorkOS
built a whole product
around detecting and
blocking bot abuse and fraud.
So this emerges here.
It's very hard to tell the
difference between the agent
that's trying to do
something good for a user
and a bot that's malicious.
But OAuth is a well-loved, in some cases,
some cases not so loved, protocol
that can actually be adapted for identity
for agentic systems.
Cool.
Second here is something called UMA,
user-managed access.
So this is actually an extension to OAuth.
And it allows a user, which
is like the resource owner,
to actually proactively
grant another party,
another person, access to a resource.
And you do this through
a centralized server.
So this is a way that users
can give consent for resources.
And essentially what
it's doing is, as a user,
it's allowing you to set policies
for what an agent can access.
For AI agents, they
could use this to control
what a personal assistant
is able to do or not do.
It's essentially taking the policy
and externalizing the consent
to this third-party system
that's giving the grant,
rather than baking it
into every single OAuth consent dialogue.
So think about an example here.
You know when you sign into
something and it's like,
hey, I wanna connect to your calendar,
connect to your Google Calendar.
When you hit approve, you're
giving that thing access
to all of your Google
Calendar kind of forever.
With something like UMA, you
could actually give it access
to a sub-resource that could
be escalated or de-escalated
after that initial consent,
to kind of separate
the permission resource
authorization step from
the initial authentication
authorization connection.
Pretty powerful stuff.
And this is, again, it's
an extension to OAuth.
It's already out there in the wild.
It's not really used that much.
There's a lot of interesting stuff
that's in the OAuth specs and extensions
that are sort of becoming
more relevant with agents.
Bunch of ideas that
people had over the years
that didn't really catch on,
but now with agents, they're more popular.
And this is one I think
that has a lot of potential.
So if you haven't heard
of UMA, check it out.
Another one, increasing
our acronyms, is GNAP.
Sounds very cool.
The Grant Negotiation and
Authorization Protocol.
You can look up the RFC if
you want some bedtime reading.
GNAP is actually designed
for dynamic negotiation
of token scopes.
So I mentioned this before.
The previous one was about resources.
It's actually the resources
that it's connecting to.
GNAP is actually about
the scopes or claims
in the token itself.
So rather than resources
like a document or an object
or a piece of code or something,
this can be about the capabilities,
the kind of actions that it can take.
And this actually lets the
client that's interacting
with it negotiate dynamically
and receive these tailored tokens.
So going back to what
I was saying previously
about the capability-based access tokens,
this doesn't create
different tokens for it.
It's like the same token,
but you can kind of scope it up and down.
And this is a really flexible framework.
I haven't really seen that many examples
of people building stuff with it.
Weirdly, it's like many years old.
It feels like it was designed today.
I think it's actually an exceptional fit
for what we'll need for AI agents.
It's just sort of a question whether
all the people building stuff now
will go back and read this or
we'll just build something new.
But this is pretty fantastic.
It essentially is a big improvement
on this static scope model that OAuth has.
And the static scopes are one
of the biggest challenges,
not just around agent development,
but I think generally OAuth.
It's a big detriment to OAuth.
There's a lot of people
that will go through
and connect their Google
account to something,
for example, and forget
that they connected it.
It's very hard to deescalate those scopes.
You have to deactivate the whole thing.
You can't escalate or deescalate.
So GNAP is a grant negotiation
authorization protocol.
So it's really like a
dynamic negotiation protocol.
OIDCA, this is the OpenID
extension for agents.
Now, this is very early.
It's actually in a blog
post from earlier this year,
a couple of people working on it.
When I talked about this a few months ago,
someone very angrily
came up to me and told me
it's not in the spec, so I
shouldn't be talking about it,
but I think it's really cool.
It's an extension to
actually OpenID Connect
that's specifically built for agents.
So all the stuff I mentioned
earlier around OIDC
not being good for people
actually logging in,
the kind of dynamic system,
this actually is an extension
that makes it possible for agents.
So it's this emerging standard.
And it standardizes a
lot of these attributes
around the model, the
provider, the version,
the instance ID, all the agent
systems that you would want.
So it kind of brings
structure to that world.
I don't know the current state of it
if it's actually gonna make
it into the OIDC stuff,
but again, these are some very good ideas
to go build on top of if you're interested
in extending your own OIDC
framework for developers.
And in particular, this actually has stuff
for doing capability discovery.
So one of the differences
between OAuth and OIDC
is you can actually have
this kind of discovery step
that you can see what's
possible in the system.
And this lets you kind of
like check the permissions
that might be available beforehand.
So OIDC-A.
And the very last one here,
you've almost made it through
all the acronyms, is SCP.
The Secure Credential Presentation.
Have any of you heard
of the Verifiable
Credentials Project, VCs?
This is through the W3C.
This is something that was
kind of like the Web 2.0 era.
People were really talking about it.
They're really excited.
It was the idea that you could have
like a personal credential that's created
and verified by some third party
that can be verified anywhere.
So if you like went to
Stanford and you got a degree,
you could actually have sort
of a cryptographic signed credential
that you have a CS degree from Stanford.
And you could show that to anyone
and they could verify it
with Stanford's public key.
It's really powerful.
It was actually built for humans,
but this is something that has a lot
of potential to be applied for people.
Some of the architectural
patterns I mentioned earlier,
you can use verifiable
credentials to provide that.
This can be the tokens that you can pass
from machine to machine
'cause it can be verified
in sort of a stateless way.
There's actually an OIDC
extension for this too.
OpenID Connect for
Verifiable Presentations,
is what it's called.
So you take these,
verifiable credentials is
actually separate from OIDC.
You can put the two together.
So acronym soup, there's
a lot of different things.
I hope this standardizes
a little bit more.
If I'm gonna give a talk
here at re:Invent next year
about this, it'd be nice
to have like one acronym
instead of five, but that's
the world we're in today.
All right, we'll start to talk
about some industry
approaches and tools next.
So it's super, super early around how
actually people are building with agents.
But there's an approach that we've taken
and we've actually built
products around this
in terms of how you can
bring authentication
and identity to your agentic systems.
And it's a pattern that
we've used for many years.
It's middleware.
So the idea here is really
to take your application,
your agent code in some way,
and isolate it from
these third party systems
you're connecting it
to with a shared layer
that's actually doing the authentication
and authorization at some boundary.
And this is what we've built at WorkOS.
We are an identity authentication company.
If you've logged into products
like ChatGPT, Enterprise,
or Cloud, or Perplexity,
Cursor, how many of you have used Cursor?
Yeah, a ton of people.
We're actually running that as middleware.
We're an authentication middleware system.
And this same thing will work for agents.
We've built a product called AuthKit,
which is a full identity
end-to-end package for this.
And we actually have also figured out
how to build a middleware system
for doing authorization,
fine-grained authorization.
It's kind of built
around some of the ideas
that Google had with Zanzibar,
but resource-level permissions.
And so this model of just building
this kind of interface layer
gives your agent developers
a lot of tools and a lot of flexibility
and really leverage to go
build expressive applications
and have their code do crazy things
and call out to LLMs and
have them do the reasoning,
get all the benefit you
have from the LLM systems,
get all the juice out of that fruit,
but not expose yourself to risk,
not expose yourself to
potential attack or issues.
We've actually even built
in the middleware system,
I mentioned some of our fraud stuff,
you can also protect your app
against agents doing weird stuff.
So we have a product called Radar
that actually blocks fraud and abuse
and detects anomalous behavior.
And we run it in the same way
as this kind of application middleware.
So the same patterns that we've been using
for a long time for traffic,
for web-based systems on the internet,
we can use for agents, which is thankful.
There's a lot of
interesting stuff being done
also around identity for
agents from other vendors.
I know we're at the AWS conference,
but I have to say Microsoft Entra
is like a really, really
popular identity system
that a ton of companies use,
like enterprise identity thing.
And they recently
introduced Entra Agent ID.
So you can think about provisioning agents
coming from the human identity system.
There's a lot of interesting
stuff coming out of that.
We're working with them
to hopefully standardize
on some protocols there.
And then also around the
industry standards for this,
there's some pretty interesting stuff
happening from the IGA vendors,
like ConductorOne, it's a
pretty interesting startup
if you haven't seen them.
It's really used by IT for
human-based kind of permissioning
and it's a very natural
extension to move that to agents.
So a lot of cool stuff
happening in the industry.
What's next?
What's next for this?
Going, kind of rewinding
back a little bit,
trust used to be the barrier.
It was black and it was white.
You had code that was trusted,
code that your team wrote,
'cause we all know our
code is not full of bugs
if we wrote it, it's trusted.
And then you had untrusted code,
things that might have been packages,
open source things
downloaded from the internet,
you sandbox it, you run it in some type
of isolated container, you
don't trust its behavior.
But we really had these
two different worlds,
trusted versus untrusted.
And this has really gone away.
It's very hard now to say
what's trusted and untrusted.
Everything's a gray area.
What is real?
What is fake?
How can you tell that the
code that's been authored
by the AI system, the
agent, is actually correct
or trust or not?
You can't.
And the same thing is true, actually,
with code that's written by your humans,
'cause humans are using AI
systems to write a lot of code.
So it's not just the code
that's being written,
it's the actual behavior
of the applications
and the kind of end-to-end system
of how these systems work in production.
And even if you can trust the code itself,
these LLM systems are super dynamic.
In fact, they're very,
very non-deterministic.
They have this stochastic behavior,
and the models are changing constantly.
If you're calling out
to a third-party model,
it could be totally different tomorrow.
And so you can't really
trust anything anymore,
is what I'm trying to say.
Previously, you could have
some code that you would run,
you'd put it on a box, you'd be like,
okay, I'm gonna trust it's
gonna do the same thing
for the next 10 years.
If you're plugging it into
one of these AI systems,
good luck.
Today's apps are primarily used,
say like 95% of them is by people.
If you ship a new product,
if you ship the new service,
your humans are onboarding it,
and maybe like 5% of
the traffic is some API,
some Zapier thing maybe that
connects or some automation.
If you build a task tracking app,
like a JIRA or a linear competitor,
mostly it's gonna be people using it.
And then maybe there'll
be some automated things,
automated bug reports
or whatever right in it.
But I think that this
is actually gonna shift.
It's already shifting,
especially with things like linear,
where agents are becoming actually
an increasing use case here.
They're going from being
maybe 1%, 0% or 1% or 5%.
To some point,
I think that they'll
actually be like 50, 50%.
Fit 50/50.
And then at some point,
agents might be actually
the dominant set of users.
There might be products that are created
first for agents and second for people.
That you're just as a human
kind of stepping in to
override the system.
It's not actually designed for you.
And this is a huge architectural shift
around building products and services,
and honestly also building companies.
If we think back to the
early infrastructure
that was API first,
companies like Stripe
that launches an API,
I think that there will be
companies that are agent first.
They launch and provide their service
not to humans, but to agents.
And there'll be a whole
economy around agents.
This might sound far-fetched,
but these things happen
slowly and then all at once.
And there will be actually
more agents than people.
People, we're pretty slow to create.
Long time horizon.
Agents, you can make new
ones very, very fast.
And so it's not hard to imagine
with the seven billion
people we have in the world
that there will likely be
trillions and trillions of agents
popping into existence,
dissolving, doing tasks for us.
And the way that modern products will work
and the way that modern
applications will leverage this
will determine whether it'll
be successful in the market
or not.
And the way that companies leverage it
will determine whether they're successful
and competitive or not.
It's gonna be really,
really, really, really big.
Billions of people, trillions of agents,
one giant problem to solve
around identity and authentication.
So if you're interested in this,
if you have thoughts around this
or you're working with
agents inside of your company
or maybe just noodling
around or curious about it,
I encourage you to come
chat with me right now
after this talk or send
me a message later.
I'm really, one of the
reasons I'm here at reInvent
is to meet folks like you
and to hear about what
you're all building.
So hopefully we can collaborate together
and build this very exciting
future for AI agents
and rapidly bring this world to fruition
and do it in a way that's
very secure and safe.
Thanks so much.
(audience applauding)